I am really excited to be here so thank
you all for having well we're thrilled
to have you thank you so much for being
here Cheryl so there's a lot to talk
about today you're a new book option B
but where I'd really love to start is
with early part of your career so you
left the Treasury in 2001 and you were
contemplating various different
opportunities here in Silicon Valley one
of which was to join Google as its first
business unit manager and and Eric
Schmidt is a lecturer here he was also a
piece in the top guess recently did he
really tell you - don't be stupid just
get on the rocket ship yes he did
I am read it's an interesting day to be
here because today Mark Zuckerberg my
boss is giving the Harvard commencement
where he and I both went but I graduated
mm-hmm
saying only what about finished but he
gets he gets his degree he gets his
degree today but I was working on my
post and I'm going to do a post after
his graduation as speech finishes in an
hour or so and you know what I said is
that when I graduated from college Mark
Zuckerberg was in elementary school
specifics and the lesson you draw from
that and I really mean this so deeply is
like you know two career thoughts one is
do not try to draw a straight line and
the second is cyan't find the rocket
ship that matters to you dad sorry on
the first and you know what really
matters here is if you try to plan out
your career anyone who thinks you know
exactly what you're going to do for the
next 30 years here's what I promise or
four years it's going to be boring and
you're going to miss all the good stuff
because all the good stuff hasn't been
invented yet the thing that's really
going to change the world you don't yet
know what it was and so if I had mapped
out my career you know mark was in
elementary school and there was no
internet right there's no internet when
I graduated from college and so I tell
people you want to have a really long
run dream and you want to have a short
run plan and that short run plan and
it's important
it's not about what you accomplish
especially in the early days it's about
what you help other people accomplish
and about what you learn you invest in
yourself you invest in the success of
your teams of other people and and that
and network and the second is the rocket
ship lesson so I was at the Treasury I
didn't really ever think I'd live in
California but from the point of view of
the US Treasury all the exciting stuff
was happening out here in these
companies that didn't exist and so I
wanted to work in Silicon Valley but it
was actually hard it was 2000 2000 2001
lots of people said I would never hire
anyone like you to my face there was a
huge bus the tech first tech bubble had
just burst and so it was actually hard
to get a job and when I finally got one
at Google it felt like the wrong job I
had a spreadsheet some of you have those
it had my criteria for my job and the
problem with the Google job is other
than loving the company it meant none of
the criteria I was a business unit
general manager but you know I'm not
that dumb there were no business units
this is so that job title didn't mean
anything it was also a couple levels
lower than other job offers I had
elsewhere and Eric said he put his hands
on my little spreadsheet when I showed
him my criteria and how Google meant
none of it except that I loved the
company and said you loved the mission
this is a rocket ship when you get
offered a seat on the rocket ship you
don't ask what seat and this is one of
the most common career mistakes I see
people make all the time
all of someone coming out of government
or someone who's in legal or someone
who's in marketing and they want to
change careers they want to move from
marketing to sales it's not hard maybe
it's not a good example from legal to
marketing or from politics or industries
and then you'll say okay we're willing
to take a chance on you you'll start
here and they're like but that's three
levels lower or two years behind and
look at them unlike if you're going to
work for the next 40 years why did you
care get yourself and the job I took at
Google and the job I took at Facebook
were more junior than every other job
offer I had right but they turned out to
be much bigger opportunities and so when
you're facing that decision of joining
mark when he was I think 23 at the time
younger than most of
in the room what advice could you offer
to us those of us who find ourselves in
a non founding leadership position about
respecting the founders culture while
also making your own impact so there are
a lot of founder driven companies out
here there are elsewhere but I think
it's broader than that I think the
lesson is about how do you build the
relationships at work that are going to
last and it turns out it's immensely
similar to building relationships at
home you know what matters relationships
in your friendship what matters is that
you care about the other people you have
aligned goals right when you've had
friends think about friendships in your
life we've all had this where you've had
friends that you kind of wanted the same
things and you stayed good friends for a
long time or a boyfriend or girlfriend
and sometimes that doesn't work but if
you want the same things and then you're
willing to care about the person and
really know the person you can make it
work probably the best advice I got from
this was from Dave my husband when I was
interviewing with mark mark and I
actually had a lot of stuff we had we
thought that we didn't agree that we
couldn't figure it out what was going to
be Facebook's business model you know
what were we going to do on these things
and what Dave said to me is you said
don't even bother sorting out the
substance before you take the job
because all you'll have done is sorted
out today's substance and it'll all
change what you need to sort out before
you take the job as the process can you
and Mark disagree on something and work
it out can you convince him of something
he didn't believe and does he convince
you an awful lot of things he believes
because a lot of the stuffs going to go
his way pay attention to the process and
we spent a couple months really spending
a lot of time together and in that time
I learned a lot and he convinced me of
lots of things I hadn't thought of
before and there were one or two times
where I convinced him and I watched him
accept my point of view and then on the
way in I didn't ask him for anything
except a commitment to the process of
our relationship so all I asked for was
we'd sit together we would always have
meetings so we agreed we'd have the
first meeting of the week in the last
meeting of the week just the two of us
and we would and I asked him he would
always give me feedback once a week and
he jumped in and said
as long as you give me feedback once a
week and that was when I took the job
was when he said that so paying
attention to the process by which you're
going to work with someone on the way
into a job along with values alignment
alignment of what the purpose of the
company is I think is the most important
thing you can do and he's really grown
into a friend
it sounds like he and his wife Priscilla
were incredible to you following dates
passing can you can you share a little
bit more about how that friendship has
evolved over the years yeah people used
to write about us that we were like the
Silicon Valley Odd Couple you know and
and maybe in some ways we were but we're
not now I mean he is one of my
absolutely closest friends in the world
and so is Priscilla you know Mark's an
incredible person and not just the
brilliance we see and Facebook but if
you have a chance to watch his
commencement speech today watch it
because it has a very clear vision of
what a global and connected world is
that is a vision that he really has that
I think would be very good for the world
and is feeling like it needs more
support than it has right now and he's
putting that out there into the world in
a very brave in a very bold way and I'm
proud of him for doing that um as a
friend you know when they've died mark
he didn't just help me but he really
helped build my self-confidence back up
I was one of the most surprising things
about losing Dave was that you know I
wrote lean in I thought about self
confidence and awful live and I think
years running around you know we've
32000 leaned in circles in 150 countries
like I've spent years giving other
people other women advice on how to
build their self-confidence and in
giving that advice I really thought I
understood my own and had built my own
up I was pretty open in the book in
areas where I didn't have enough but
when Dave died I didn't think I was
capable of anything
I could barely go to work and not cry I
was parenting on my own two grieving
children and what happened before Dave
died is that when someone was having a
problem at work and people have real
ship that they're going through and then
they come to work I would think my job
was to take the pressure off them I'm so
sorry this is happening do you not want
to be here but what I figured out is
that when I came back to work and people
said to me this kind of things I said to
them oh don't worry you know of course
you can't concentrate with all your
going through that really undermine my
self-confidence because it made me feel
like oh my god that's exactly right what
Marx did was take as much time as you
want and companies need better policies
I'm very proud of Facebook's you know
take as much time as you want but he
also did but you made a really good
point today and so what I learned is now
and people are facing hardship at work I
will both give them time off but I will
say but here's the project if you want
it we still believe in you and that's
true not just with death it's true of
people who have been diagnosed with an
illness I've talked to so many people
who are working through cancer and you
know they'll talk about I have chemo
brain no one thinks I can do anything so
if every time you interact with them
you'd say oh don't worry that's helpful
but throw in a couple of good things
they did as long as they're true and
legitimate and that's even more helpful
right and so let's let's take a step
back so you're on vacation with Dave and
Friends the unimaginable as you say
happens and you fly home to tell your
two young children that their father was
gone the morning of his funeral you've
decided to start writing a journal and
that turned into a very famous and
widely seen Facebook post why did you
decide to chair your very personal story
so publicly I mean I never thought I
would I am after Dave died it wasn't
just the grief which was so overwhelming
it was really this pretty deep sense of
isolation
you know before Dave died when I dropped
my kids off at school to go to local
public school here in Menlo Park
everyone would chitchat I'd go to work
and everyone would chitchat but after
Dave died I was walking around I felt
like a ghost you know everywhere I went
was just kind of silence and that's
because people were so afraid of saying
the wrong thing that they didn't say
anything at all and so I've been keeping
this journal and when the Jewish period
of mourning which is chella shame thirty
days of coming to a close I thought
about like writing what I would say if I
were just honest and I wrote the post
and then I went to bed the night before
thinking there's zero chance I'm posting
this it's way too honest and then I woke
up the next day and it really was so bad
I thought to myself can't get worse my
Kipp father and I hit post and it helps
I mean it didn't take the grief away and
it didn't bring Dave back but it took
away the isolation because people
started talking to me again a friend of
mine at work said she's been driving by
my house every month every day actually
for a month and had never come in so she
started coming in strangers started
talking to strangers and what I realized
through this process as my own grief but
also talking other people is that all of
these challenges assure these huge
elephants into the room right you want
to silence a room say you have cancer
you will completely silence any room you
are in
your dad just went to prison you just
lost your job any of these things you
lost a child your child is sick your
husband I mean just any of these things
you can even feel quiet in the room when
I say it up here and so that means that
we don't help each other when we need
each other the most and one of the
reasons I wrote option B and I'm glad
that out of desperation I did share
publicly is I want to try to kick those
elephants out of those rooms because
they're not helping anyone get through
it and it doesn't mean any will ever
want to talk about things all the time
they don't
but looking at someone and saying I know
you're suffering I know this is hard and
I'm here when you want to talk when you
want to cry or when you want to just be
I am here we can have an awful lot more
of those conversations than we do the
other thing I learned through this is
that one of the ways we offer help and I
give this all the time was we say is
there anything I can do when we offer to
help that's actually the most common
thing we do right that's what I used to
do the problem is when you're on the
other side of that it kind of shifts the
burden for the person who's being needs
to help to come up with something and
most the time you have no idea what to
say I mean what runs through my mind
every time is chemic fathers they go
away so I don't have to live through it
like not going to happen
so there's a really nice story in my
book about Ganon Esther levy they're
community members of our community here
and they had a child who died very
tragically they're in the hospital for
many months and a friend of his showed
up at the hospital and texted from the
hospital lobby and said I'm in the haa
I'm in the lobby for a hug for the next
hour whether you want it or not and so a
friend of mine read this in my blog
option B and a friend of hers who's miss
important part of the story she's not
very close friends just a friend
when is the hospital with her daughter
and so she said what she would have done
is exactly nothing because when a friend
goes to the hospital you don't show up
that's totally imposing but shred my
book so she went to the toy store she
bought a big stuffed giraffe she went to
the lobby of the hospital and said I'm
here with the toy I could just leave it
downstairs but in case you're free and
the woman immediately texted back and
said please come upstairs and she gave
the four-year-old who has leukemia to
toy and she was unwrapping it the
mother's standing behind her crying the
whole time saying thank you for showing
up and in the hour she was there no one
else did you don't have to be someone's
best friend from the first grade and you
don't have to be a personal friend you
can be a work friend to show up and we
can do a lot more to show up for each
other to feel each other's pain
acknowledge kick elephants out of the
room and be there for one another and
it'll make us stronger as friends a
family as community and as colleagues
wherever we work one of the interesting
things that you write about in an option
B is that children are naturally more
resilient than adults are what have you
learned from your own children about how
to bounce back after adversity yeah
children are sometimes so just to be
clear because it's very it's very
important to understand children can be
more resilient than adults so children
also need a lot of support so children
need to build resilience they need to
build a resilience for trauma like mine
have faced they need to build resilience
for a lot of the things we don't provide
I mean we have a problem in this country
where you know we have 37 percent of
single moms living in poverty 40% of
your black or Latina and the poverty
line is low so many many more people are
facing real challenges of putting food
on the table and so these children are
not getting
education they're not getting the
support they need from our government
they're not getting the support they
need from communities and so those
children need more than resilience they
need actual support and actual education
and actual health care and we need to
provide that and then there's the
everyday challenges in children need
resilience for that too and so there are
very specific things we can do to build
resilience in our children and one of
them and probably the most important is
something close that colleges call
mattering tell kids they matter your
opinion matters to me what you do
matters to me I want your advice your I
care about your opinion and I want you
to know mine treat them like the people
they are another thing I think is really
important in building resilience then we
wrote about in the book but I see it a
lot in the workplace is don't do too
much for your kids and for you guys
please don't let your parents do things
for you if your parent is about to email
a friend to get you a job don't let that
happen
people do not want to hire people whose
parents apply for them I'm dead serious
I get three of these a week I am dead
serious
do not let your parents do stuff for you
you are communicating to your future
employer that you can't do it yourself
it is a generational thing that did not
exist in my generation but it is a big
deal that's going on in the workforce I
promise if I get two resumes from
someone directly and from someone's
parent I'm always going to hire the
first we have to let our kids and you
guys have to let yourselves do things on
their own because that is how you build
resilience you grew up in a family of
very strong women what from your
upbringing prepared you for this level
of success that you've achieved working
on things that matter my parents were
very nonprofit focused and very focused
on doing the right thing for the right
reason and I think hard work I mean all
that all the stuff out there on grit and
determination and working in things that
are challenging is all true and
something that's just super important
for there's no substitute for for
I work and I think one thing that I see
generationally that's happened and I
think we can do a better better job on
this is we need to remind kids that
they're not just doing for them they're
contributing and we need to remind
people of that in the workplace the best
hiring story ever is that I ever had
experienced is in lean in is Laurie
Koller she called me when I went to
Facebook and she called and said the
following she says I think I want to
come work with you at Facebook she was
at eBay in marketing so I thought I'd
call you and tell you all the things I
like to do in all the things I'm good at
but I figure everyone's doing that so
instead I'm going to call you and say
what's your biggest problem and how can
I solve it so you know lean and sold
millions of copies millions of people
have hopefully read at least part of the
book right at that story but I don't see
that many people coming into the
workplace asking what they can do for
the company
ask what you can do I promise you we'll
get mentors you will get sponsors you
will get results you will get promotions
you will get opportunities by
contributing if it is about you it won't
happen because organizations are not
about you organizations are about or the
organization and their mission and when
you serve that mission and when you work
hard towards the betterment of the
people around you and I think I learned
that at home that's where real success
comes from but you can't fake it you
can't be like I'm going to pretend to
care about everyone else in our mission
to get myself ahead that won't work you
actually have to care you have to go
work someplace with people you can care
about and with a mission you can care
about you you publish lean in in 2013
and as you said it's gone on to sell
millions of copies in it you wrote a
chapter called make your partner a real
partner and you share an anecdote about
how they've taught you how to diaper
your son and also that 26 of the 28
women who served as fortune 500 CEOs and
were married and so do you still view it
as essential or really important to to
women's success that they have a partner
I mean it's definitely a chapter I
regretted once Dave died you know I
wrote about different forms of families
structure in lean in but I wrote a
chapter called met your partner real
partner and then when I didn't have one
I thought about how hard that would be
to read just like the father-daughter
dance is just brutal for the kids in art
of a father and I wish they could just
call it something else
Katie Couric her her husband died as
well so in her private school in New
York she tried to get them to change it
and they told her it was tradition and
she spoke back on a whole bunch of other
things that were also tradition like
slavery that are long gone but she was
like just because something's
traditional does not mean it's a good
right it's a good idea right and so not
to compare the two let's be clear one is
far worse than the other but just
because we've done something the wrong
way doesn't mean we should continue to
do it I don't have a partner I can no
longer say that I know I never said in
Lena and you had to have one and I was
clear about that I did say you should
pick the right one that if you are going
to have a partner if you're going to
have a same-sex partner same-sex
partners share tours more Amalie so it's
actually less of an issue on average
it's always an issue for any few people
in the world to work out what if you are
going to have a partner and you are
woman and that partner is going to be a
man picking someone who supports your
career is a really big deal and it does
make me pretty sad the data on your
generation is your attitudes are not
that much better than mine the data in
my generation they're getting better a
little bit right the basic sub sub is
the expert they're getting better a
little bit but we don't we don't take
surveys and find out that you know 98
percent of the men who are graduating
from college and Business School this
year I think their wives should have the
same career they have that's not what it
says it should say that it doesn't say
that so you might as well know that
about the dating pool
and find the ones who are answering the
question the right way I'm serious I'm
dead serious advocacy aid all different
types of data where men don't marry them
the ones who quietly if you are a woman
and you are an ambitious woman and I
hope you are because men have run the
world for a long time it's not going
that well so I hope every woman in here
is ambitious and I hope every man is
here is ambitious for the women in his
life but if you are a woman and if you
are ambitious and if you want a
leadership role which I hope you all are
you know don't marry the guy who when
they fill out the survey and no one's
there says my career is more important
because you know what his career is
going to be more important there's a lot
of societal pressure which still exists
which is reinforcing that and while we
work to change it in society because we
owe you that you can change it in your
own home by picking the right home in
the first place many of the stories that
you Sharon Lee and then are about men
who've championed your career from
secretary summers to mark and Dave what
role have women played well have never
worked for a woman and most women have
never worked for a woman because
especially the more senior you get
because we still have basically five
percent of the fortune 500 CEO jobs or
their equivalent everywhere in the world
and so the first thing we can do is
change that by all of you but women have
played a really important important
career and I think it's worth really
understanding how important it is for
women to support each other and also
getting rid of what I think is largely a
myth now that women don't support each
other I also think when we look for
support looking to our peers is much
more important than people talk about
and get credit there's endless classes
and seminars and breakout sessions at
every conference on finding a mentor and
that's important and mentorships and
sponsorship is important and you have to
go about it the right way but peers can
be just as important and just as
effective lean in circles were founded
with the idea that our peers could
mentor us based on a lot of research and
there are now almost 33,000 in 150
countries we grow by almost 100 a week
and we find that the people in them do
take on more challenges are are you know
able to fulfill their dreams at a higher
level and they believe their circles are
helping them so when you look for that
support women playing that role in your
career lean in circle or some structure
where you are relying on people
explicitly can be really helpful and it
doesn't have to be people above you can
be your peers they can be incredibly
effective you offered some interesting
advice backstage that having a personal
board of directors or branding yourself
is horrible advice so I would love to
hear a little more about that yeah these
are two really bad piece of advice I
don't know if you're giving them here so
if anyone's giving them here I apologize
in advance but I wrote him lean in don't
ask someone to be your mentor don't walk
up to someone and say will you be my
mentor here's why that doesn't work
because a mentorship is a real
relationship there's a relationship
where someone invests in you and you
invest back in them and I've mentored
lots of people over many many decades
not one of which started with me to be
my mentor the way it started was you
know I learned from someone and they
learn from me I mean I would say Debra
and failed us here she's been my mentor
in learning all the data on women she
was nice at next door to dinner she was
the first person who'd never had this
conversation we're having it publicly
because she was it that's the best
possible way and she was the first
person Deb was the first person who told
me that
likeability and success for women were
negatively correlated I felt like the
life went on I understood something I
followed up I then gave a TED talk on it
I'm the only doing one side of this but
I think what happened is she taught me
something I paid her back by investing
in those ideas she really cared that
people know those ideas she now serves
on the llenan board and she mentors me
in that way and hopefully I've given
back in lots of ways and it's a real
relationship it started with substance
the real relationships start with
substance being on someone's personal
board of directors what you're saying is
hi it's all about me and I'm going to
come to you for your advice people
people don't have boards of directors
companies do this
people have relationships and those
relationships go both ways I promise if
you are Laurie Golar
and you solve the problem of the senior
people around you they will mentor you
all day they'll probably never call it
that but they will do it and if you ask
for a lot of help but you don't give
back it won't be real and you will not
get the support that you're looking for
so asking someone to be on your personal
board of directors is just way worse
than solving a problem for them for them
which you have the opportunity to do
even as the most junior person in an
organization oh and the personal
branding yeah I feel strongly about this
since people don't have brands Colgate
has a brand you know this water has a
brand and I think it's really important
because their branding is a very
specific thing I do a lot of work on
branding I think about how Facebook's
brand evolve I think about I'm in the
advertising business so I work with
companies all over the world on their
brand and when you are selling a product
you are trying to package it and explain
it I'm going to walk by on a shelf and
I'm going to decide what toothpaste and
that's a decision it's a decision that's
important to me I used toothpaste many
times a day and it's a very important
decision for the companies and how that
how that value proposition is packaged
explained clearly and simply is how I'm
going to make that decision along with
price and convenience of where it's sold
that's what products need to be they
need to be packaged cleanly neatly
concretely people aren't like that if
you are trying to package yourself
you're almost certainly salts and by the
way to be fair to people who do give
this advice I don't think that's what
they mean I think they are giving more
nuanced and careful advice I just think
in its interpretation it's having a
negative effect because we are messy you
know who am i I am the CEO of Facebook a
company I definitely believe and I am
the founder of llenan and option B I'm
an author I'm a mom I'm a widow at some
level I'm still deeply heartbroken I am
a friend and I am a sister
and there are people in my life I'm not
in touch with anymore like I am a lot of
very messy complicated things and if I
put myself out there or even with a
friend sit and I am not honest about all
of those things I am NOT real and I
don't think people should try to package
themselves up because it's not real so
Scotty McClellan is here he's been one
of the most important people in my life
I took his class when I was in business
school I think some of you are fortunate
enough to be here taking this class
right now and that's what your class is
about it is about who we are as people
and nowhere in there would you ever give
anyone advice to simplify or package or
put one face out to the world because
that is exactly the opposite of what we
need from each other and from ourselves
and we men you write about how it's a
fallacy to that you can have it all but
people don't have it all it's a question
of can you do it all and the answer is
often no but in your case it does seem
like from the outsider's perspective you
you do it all and so from your own point
of view what are you what have you given
up or what choices have you made to do
all that you have founding lean in and
option B and and and leading one of the
biggest tech companies in the world well
the most important thing I do is I hire
really well I have amazing teams as one
person you can see what Facebook does we
have 16,000 unbelievable people and I
have an unbelievable boss and leader and
partner and Mark and you know my
foundation
you know option B launched I don't know
a month ago we have 350,000 people in
the community in the community is really
helping people with helping me that's
because my foundation team rocks and so
it's never about one person I could
never do all this but if I have a great
team and great working relationships
with people together we can do an awful
lot the having it all concept is so
problematic you know you are all a
little young so I'll try to do the
younger being bit so they put four four
though many were older and so let me do
this four men in the room has anyone
ever questioned should you work you sure
you want to work
okay we're all out of business school so
might be biased but again this may not
work because of age but I promise it'll
work with the older women here for women
who are here has anyone ever said should
you be working and so what you guys
can't see is keep your hands up
every woman in this room who's above 40
has her hand up
no I'm serious there is no woman in this
there's note you cannot no matter what
you do you can have my career yours any
career you cannot get to the age of 40
as a woman in the United States without
someone asking you if you should work
okay
70% of mothers in the workplace most
women have to work we never ask men how
they have it all
I get asked by reporters all the time I
always say the same thing I won't answer
that question because you don't ask men
right they say oh yes I always ask men
I'm like great show me the article where
you've asked the man oh I know right
into the article what I always asked out
here's were they right I stopped
answering that question I just said show
me the interview where you asked me that
question
there is no how do you do it all to a
man no one asks that because what we're
saying is that you can't have a career
and you can't have a family and this is
so important I think it'd be a Jola most
of you are which is we tell women they
can't do it all and they leave before
they leave they leave before they leave
that we I am watching woman after woman
after woman lean back because they're
going to have kids one day I've given a
lot of talks with a lot of companies and
I'll say to roomfuls with people like
this stand up if you want to be CEO of
your company and you know some of the
men will stand up very few of the women
and if you ask why a lot of the women
will say well I want to have a family
and then I say okay who's had a meeting
with the CEO and they raise their hand I
say keep your hand up if the meeting was
set on your schedule turns out that
meeting was set on the CEO schedule
people miss that as you get more senior
you often have more control not less now
not all the time and there's always
exceptions but what's really happening
is that men are being told to keep their
foot on the gas
women are subtly subtly often leaning
back and then fast forward ten years in
the workplace they're both working
full-time the woman is just making less
less senior end has less control over
schedule for those kids and so even if
you're not 100% sure you're going to
stay in even if you've been told over
and over again you can't do it all
either by watching women like me be
interviewed and asked that question or
because people have said it directly to
you just stay in until you leave because
that gives you the optimal choices and
then you can decide and I've never said
everyone should stay in the workforce I
really want people to follow their own
dreams and for a lot of people working
in the home is the most gratifying thing
they can do I just want women to make
that from a place of strength I want
them to have the best job they can
possibly have and then make that I want
them to have partners who are doing
their share in the home and then make
those decisions in lean in you write and
encourage the readers to make decisions
as if you were unafraid what is one
thing that you're afraid of that you've
yet to do well I just did option B so I
feel like that counts for right now I'm
in the middle of doing it so my but I
wrote a book on my husband's death and
and what it's like and what is grief and
what is resilience and what is trying to
rebuild and so that's actually a pretty
scary thing so I don't think I have my
next thing yet but I know why I did it I
did it because I want something good to
come out I mean John was right dave was
beloved and beloved in this community um
at his funeral and I know somebody in
the front where were there with me our
friend Xander asked the crowd raise your
hand if devolver changed her life and I
mean a sea of hands went up it was
extraordinary and I know if dave was
still alive he'd be doing so much good
for so many people and so if from his
death we can do option B and we can help
other people recover I feel that it
honors the life he led and so it is
still hard and still scary sometimes to
talk about it but I feel like I'm
trying to do some good my favorite story
in the book the book is on my story a
lot of really good research and a lot of
stories of other people who have faced
resilience and some pretty important
stuff on resilience for companies and
careers in case you're interested um my
favorite story is a guy named Joe Kasper
and he he lost his son but he was a
doctor so he dealt with other people's
life and death all the time but then his
son died so now along with being a
doctor he counsels other bereaved
parents and he says that he feels that
it extends his son's legacy and even his
son's life by doing good in his son's
name and I think the reason I did what I
was not was afraid to do which is be
this open about it was because I think
it extended stable works legacy and I do
think that there's a lesson in there in
that when you ask guy it's the question
all the time what would you do if you
weren't afraid the point is not do
stupid things you're afraid of like you
know my sister jumped out of an airplane
once I was terrified and angry I'm like
that just seems stupid to me sorry for
all you airplane jumps and anything I
mean some people have to do it because
they're serving in the military but like
you have to jump out of a plane today I
don't know maybe it's your treatment you
want to do it but what I don't mean is
what would you do if you weren't afraid
and go do it
you take risks for a reward so you do
something challenging and hard like
write this book because I'm trying to
make something good come from tragedy
you take the hard job because the
company has a meaning you take the hard
role because you believe you can make
the team better you know ask yourself
what you would do as you weren't afraid
but ask yourself why and there needs to
be a really good why for most of this so
many of us are graduating next month as
you think back on your own graduation
from from Harvard Business School what's
something that you know just in your gut
that you're capable of today that you
wish that you knew then living through
tragedy I mean I never would have
thought I gave the Harvard Business
School commencement speech 23rd 2014
maybe remember like three years ago
further back 2012
and the day I gave it the day before one
of the members of that class died he
drowned suddenly in the whole classes in
morning I wore the pen we all did and I
stopped there giving this speech
thinking oh my god there's a woman in
this audience whose husband drowned last
night I think she was there and I would
have never in a million years thought
that that I would be that that person
and I just met her she's in Houston now
and she's incredible and she's going
back to her yes the fifth year reunion
that was 2012 she's going I think this
weekend her next to her husband's class
five-year reach which i think is
incredibly brave I'm proud of her thank
you so much we'll open it up to the
audience for a few questions
reminder if you have a question please
please stand and state your name when
they bring you the mic I show my name is
Jimmy I'm a first year MBA student at
the GSB especially he had the view from
the top when we hear business leaders
speak tough and speak about what makes
them successful but you are different in
that you choose to inspire people about
speaking about overcoming loss and
overcoming your doubts how did you
choose to become this kind of a leader
it's funny I don't know if I chose to
become this kind of leader or that I
thought there were things that weren't
being said that needed to be said so I
graduated from business from undergrad
in 91 from Business School in 1995 and I
looked above me and it was all men and I
looked alongside me and there were all
these great women and I just thought
that by the time I got where I was it
would be half and it just wasn't and so
there were two thing bunch of things I
wanted to say that I thought people
weren't saying one was that men still
run the world and that's not okay like
put a stake in the ground that it's not
okay when I got on that Ted stage and I
said men still run the world everyone
gasps as if that was a surprise and to
this day I can go into rooms and say
men's store around the world and people
like yes they do what a shocker you're
like
guys you have 95% of the top shop size
this isn't that hard right but the
answer is why like what are the cultural
things that are holding us back
ready men in the audience men only raise
your hand if anyone ever called you
bossy it's always you always wanted to
women in the audience raise your hand if
anyone ever called you bossy I really I
want everyone to turn around and look at
that put your hands back up so next time
you see a little girl called bossy and
it will be this weekend if you look for
it you walk right up to the people that
called her bossy probably her parents
and you say that little girl is not
bossy that little girl has executive
leadership how you do it ready I'm going
to try that the other way that little
boy has executive leadership skills I
have done that exactly that way and
gotten a huge laugh out of every
audience in every country I've ever done
that in but here's the bad news
that's bias and if you don't think you
have it I just proved you do because the
reason we laugh is that it's funny that
a little girl has executive leadership
skills because it goes against our
expectations and type so in case you sit
here at the Stanford Business School
thinking that other people have the
biases that hold women back it's you too
I laughed you laughed it's me and it's
you we all have the stereotype that is
keeping women from leading and you just
got through two years at Stanford and it
didn't change no let's be honest that's
what I wanted to say and then I wanted
to say there's a whole bunch of stuff
women are also doing to hold themselves
back so I don't think I chose to be any
kind of leader I chose to say those
three things we need more women in
leadership the culture is holding us
back and there are things we can do and
again I think if you're looking for what
kind of lead
you're going to be you are to inwardly
focused focus on what you want to say
because it matters or what you want to
build or what you want to make or who
you want to serve and that's how you
become the kind of leader you are if
that makes sense
I'm Paul I'm a second year student and
I'm not trying to ask you if you're
going to run for president which means
that I am asking you that
let's just frame it as career advice so
you worked in the Clinton administration
and you're obviously very interested in
public service and the public sector and
for those of us who are interested in
both government and private sector work
how do you think about the pros and cons
and going forward in your career how do
you think about blending those got a
band full question good question um so
for me for my answer is I really love my
job at Facebook and it gives me what I
want to do and then no but I do have I
have a loud voice on an increasingly
loud voice on public policy you know I
know what a whole bunch of what I think
a whole bunch of policies were and I'm
increasingly using that voice and I
think I have the ability to have that
voice and it's one I'm using loudly I'm
going in and out look there's two paths
in the US government there's civil
servants where you really go in and you
move up the ladder and there's going in
and out
I think being open to doing that
thinking about running for office all of
that stuff really makes sense and I
think we need the country's best and
brightest to do this I also think we'd
be well served by having more people who
were in business in office I think about
some of the things I thought at the US
Treasury that really changed once I had
to make payroll and that was the
Treasury which is the finance department
and so I do think having more business
leaders like all of you running for
office and serving in government is
really important Bob Rubin who was the
chairman of Goldman Sachs and then the
secretary of the Treasury made that
point for a very long time and I think
it's a good one so I'm glad you asked
that question I hope a lot of you are
open to that because you can do a lot of
good
I a serious answer the question is I
feel like I'm doing I'm trying to do all
the good I can and there's always
different ways to do it but I really
believe in what Facebook's doing I
really do I believe that we need global
companies I believe that we need global
voice I believe there are four billion
people who aren't connected to data that
we can help connect but it's because I
believe that that I stay as my name is
Christophe Mayer I'm a second year here
SEO of Facebook you led the company
through tremendous growth there's
another rocket ship that's facing a few
problems right now that I here is also
looking for a see CLO what would you do
if you were the new CEO of uber I mean
it's a really hard question to answer
from the outside it's a really hard
question age from the outside I don't
understand their business deeply enough
I mean at all at all the answer but
here's what I would do I would take that
job if I had the relationship with
Travis that could really make an impact
and I felt there was a real desire to
address the issues that needed to be
addressed and it's not just a CEO job I
mean it really is as you take every role
you're going to take and you guys I mean
I'm so honored and excited to be here as
your legacy last speaker before you
graduate because how exciting you've
studied at one of the best institutions
you have these tremendous classmates
around you you're asking all of these
amazing questions like go out and make a
difference and you're going to do that
by finding things you really care about
and building relationships with the
people around you that make you care I
say have Facebook to this question that
does get asked with some frequency right
it's been nine and a half years because
I'm doing something I care about with my
best friend that's a pretty special
thing to do so whoever takes that job if
someone takes that job they have to
believe in what overs doing and they
have to believe in their relationship
with Travis and then they have to build
a team around them and it's the exact
same thing for your jobs whatever you're
about to go do if you haven't figured
or you are figuring out do something you
care about with people you believe and
focus on what you contribute that's it
and be willing to move around I wrote in
lean in that careers are jungle-gym not
a ladder careers or jungle gym
I moved sideways I didn't always move up
if I had insisted on moving up I never
would have taken the number-2 job at
Facebook I could have been see
everything else that were talking to me
about I would have been CEO I took
another job now I would run the company
but I'd rather be number two at Facebook
if that's even a concept right I mean we
have a team it's not just me and Mark
then be number one on something I don't
believe and I think the number two and
the number one is the wrong way to think
about it it's the relationship the
purpose the mission and what you can
contribute same thing your job decision
is the same as whoever is going to go PC
lol uber we have time for one final
question
hi my name is Justin I'm a first year
MBA student and kind of following on to
that you mentioned how you navigated
these different career decisions and so
with getting to these rocket ships and
like what really made those companies
and teams that you've joined standout
well I've only done it twice right I did
I did Google and Facebook with Google I
really believed in the mission of making
the world's information giving the world
information and I could see how much
easier it was I mean when Google started
you know I used to go to the library
like go to the library is literally I
grew up with Encyclopedia Britannica and
my dad's little study like it was just
bell bounding how you could just get
information on your computer I really
believe there was an unmet need in with
Facebook I felt like it turned the
lights on on who people were you know
before Facebook they that you probably
remember this there was a famous cartoon
of a dog sitting in front of the
computer and it said in the internet no
one knows you're a dog I mean the
Facebook was the first time there was
real identity on the internet so
everything I believe about being
authentic and who you are was going to
become true because of this company run
by this 23 year old it was pretty
amazing and so it was really that I
thought they were making
use these needs the other thing I'll say
is it's not along with passion I do
think it's really worth investing in
your own skills and trying the things
you're not as good at try the things
that matter
take a sales job I think too few people
out of business will take sales jobs I
felt all day I sell ads for Facebook i
DVD deals where I sell I feel every time
I'm recruiting someone I'm selling when
I'm trying to convince people we all do
that take those jobs where you're really
rolling your hands up I have a poster in
my office that I got from Howard Schultz
I served on a board of two dirty hands
and it says the future is belongs to
those of us still willing to get our
hands dirty and it's in my conference
room do something you care about and get
your hands dirty doing it you'll be able
to do anything I promise
Cheryl thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]